a sus 49 años josé gonzález vive el
momento más crítico de su vida
desde hace tres semanas tiene el kobe 19
como los hospitales están saturados su
familia trata de atenderlo en casa no
tienen dinero para comprar medicinas ni
oxígeno
por eso su cuñada sale a buscar el gas
medicinal que gratuitamente ha llegado a
su vecindario necesita requiere el
oxígeno no puede estar sin el oxígeno le
falta el aire su corazón ya se siente
que se lo está pagando su corazón sin el
oxígeno él no puede no puede estar
pacientes como jose gonzalez reciben
oxígeno gracias a esta planta móvil que
recorre los distritos más pobres de lima
basta acreditar a un pariente contagiado
para recargar gratuitamente los balones
con el gas medicinal la muerte de su
padre a causa del mortal patógeno
inspiró este joven alcalde emprender la
ayuda social que dos semanas también
viajará al interior del país el perú
sufre ya y adolece de una losa de un
déficit tremendo en cuanto al oxígeno no
razón por la cual nosotros los gobiernos
locales no no se nos hemos tenido que
unir para trabajar estrategias distintas
a las que viene trabajando el gobierno
pero pero son estrategias que esperemos
que sean replicadas por el gobierno
nacional según estadísticas oficiales
pero tiene alrededor de 500 mil
contagiados por kobe 19
joven le da temor que ante tantos
enfermos su tío de 70 años se quede sin
el oxígeno que recibe gratuitamente no
lo sabría si se acaba el oxígeno no
sabríamos la verdad qué hacer si son
mucha gente que necesitan varias
personas familiares conocidos amigos
necesitan realmente los chilenos
julia pérez ya recargo el oxígeno para
su cuñado mañana tendrá que madrugar y
repetir el mismo proceso para que su
familiar pueda seguir viviendo